bouh castaldi vous qui vous êtes marié
plus d'une dizaine de fois s'il ya
quelqu'un qui m'a commence bien la
semaine
bah oui il faut vous fait le plus
fantasmer vous voilà moi c'est sophie
marceau sophie marceau ah ouais ouais
attendait à la 50 ans franchement wemmel
a rien demandé à l'amf a rien demandé on
est magique et ne demande rien moi je
demande un doubina ebooks savait pas
plus elle s'est fait draguer par change
tout et c'est être bagué part c'est
jason statham
[Applaudissements]
25 ans j'ai alors édenté et maintenant
par qui je me fais draguer mais non
jeunes ça serait justin timberlake sur
steam timberlake
j'adore et frais leur prise de can't
stop de feeling pour bd africaine stop
de boules at il n'a pas 20 ans well as
pas d'accord il est beaucoup plus jeune
que moi non 38 c'est plein à elle à 10
ans puis soirée live vous est universel
oui
la savait quoi vous aller draguer leurs
cochons
[Applaudissements]
c'est un google phone east qu'il faut
nous prendre
tony de bourgh ma part ça serait gérée
fait râler stone away naturelle elle est
sortie brad pitt franchement très rare
non mais sans révolte et qui leur
ressemble
cvtech brad pitt elle et son big band
pitbull 10 ans non mais c'est aussi dans
la balance bon roulement mireille
mathieu et mireille mathier avait avec
la
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une des meilleures david et à
bologhine oui c'est bon elle est en
train de tout horizon fermé mais moi
aussi ma mère aussi elle a fait des
choix de la c1 mais je trouve que c'est
un mix pour un mec qui a franchi la
limite est génial moi j'adore mirail
match aussi elle roulera bien plus vrai
et on sentit ballon à deux galas santos
et je suis à l'aise hors comme toi tu es
mieux alors oui non elles la doivent à
leur garde régulièrement l'émission va
aller à paris à l'honneur de recevoir
indices vous avez laissé votre moto
c'est la seule mais j'avais en tête dans
l'émission préfère un autre sur sa main
tellement là la main chaude la vague
promesse à la moto texte c'est vrai
alors et vous mais moi tant qu'à taper
[Musique]
usagers et ben taper dans le très jeune
j'ai pris les nikki me voir me coner il
n'est pas mineur il nous l'a dit il a 19
ans non non il va recevoir 110 est moche
ou de s'amuser mais loin de leurs gardes
en battant alors à le regarder ça me
d'être un homme vêtu à deux sens ouais
bon calmez-vous quand même alors vous on
adopte un film we traduire en fils
emphaser abbaoui father elle absolument
films x je suis content parce que si
nous regardent qu'ils l'apprennent c'est
qu'ils mirent à louvain non à
l'international en arrière j'aurais visé
à brad pitt n'ont absoluement ya
plaindre tu comprends bien on l aime ou
non brad pitt j'aurais viser non 55 ans
je suis plus calme mes gars alors oui
hammami fréhaut et mamies et et j'ai un
petit doute sur vous tout à l'heure sur
moi fait sur vous saison la série brad
pitt
ouais on se ressemble énormément j'ai un
festival du film à deauville américain
j'ai pas mal et j'aurais confondues on
n'est pas une manière de faire et 5 kg
le coucher
car dans la nuit agathe au foot alors
moi si j'étais mère de famille un peu
plus âgé je jetterai mon dévolu sur noé
elmaleh kenseth a réduit au minimum 7
avec 18 ans tanner bawn 110,81 ça
grandit vite si on embrasse garder leur
très bon marin très bien très bref un
très beau et bon très bon choix et toi
au lieu de nos invités qui sont
formidables déjà à main il veut se
placer et puis sinon à l'international
je viens robert son beau client robert
moi j'adore cette actrice c'est pas du
tout aux délires